hey
what's going on
just you know work's been pretty awful
without you there you and i were
partners
you know i don't want to talk about work
is it because
what they're saying is true
[Music]
so
how the girls they're really good but
i'm working a lot you still owe me for
last friday but it can wait really oh no
i'm sorry there's 50. sorry about that
thank you hello love you guys
nurse lochren business officer braun do
you remember anna martinez rodrigo
yeah
it was sudden mind taking a look at this
huh the insulin in her system it's a
double medication error which is really
rare we understand that you work with a
charlie cullen
could he be involved in this
peter love birds i cannot get over how
cute
vanessa is
who's vanessa
oh my god
there's insulin in her system
[Music]
he's been at nine hospitals
nine oh what do you mean
no the hospital would have done
something you would think so yeah
do you remember working with someone
named charlie cullen
yeah
there was a rumor about him
they found insulin
in a dead guy's saline bag
[Music]
hey girls
come sit
are you being weird mom
he's been killing people
without ever touching him
[Music]
he's going to get a new job
and it's all going to continue i hope
you guys can hear me he's walking right
now
hey
[Music]
you